[Music]
every day is magical at Disney's Animal
Kingdom theme park
but for Mac the African bull elephant
today is once in a lifetime
so today is Mac's 40th birthday
so we are getting together a little
birthday party for him we have a
birthday cake made by our animal
Nutrition Center
I like his to see if it's his icing oh
yeah sweet potato iced tea
good boy Mac come on
no time to waste Mac loves a party
the theme is St Patrick's Day
what are you planning on using the
carrots for done
I'm gonna make little gold inside of his
pot of gold so use the watermelon for
that oh very cool okay
boy
another favorite frozen fruit treats
so I'm going to be making these ice
treats here and trying to coordinate
with the rainbow that we're doing with
the elephant team I'm going to do sweet
potatoes and carrots in one layer for
orange apples in the other for red
blueberries for blue I'll be doing
celery for green and then one of Mac's
favorites is bananas all right Matt go
on boy
it's gonna be delicious oh yeah
nailed it you guys ready ready let's go
Saint Patrick himself would approve of
this spread
honestly
it's your big birthday celebration
celebration
oh there he is
oh I'm so excited here he comes
foreign
Mac has a really big personality he's
just really fun to work with
as he's getting older you can see that
he is aging
he is a distinguished older gentleman
he definitely still has what it takes to
keep up with our younger elephants
going
look at all this other stuff
so much more
oh yeah there you go
oh happy birthday
[Music]
look there's watermelon
you deserve that pot of gold he says let
me just knock these carrots off I don't
need those they don't need the healthy
bits not necessary
[Music]
I like when it eats it and he closes his
eyes yes he looks so good what a great
birthday celebration
[Music]
oh that's a big piece
oh
he ate it
uh-oh brain freeze
[Laughter]
[Music]